the movie opens with a young boy named
vasili zaitsev being taught to hunt by
his grandfather tying their horse's bait
vasily's grandfather teaches him to stay
as Idle as a stone in order to go
undetected by the wolf as if On Cue the
animal charges towards the horse and now
frightened vasilius commanded to pull
the trigger with a lot of Courage the
trembling little boy does is told
unaware of how this significant moment
will shape him as a person the scene
then changes to 1942 when the world is
still facing the terror of World War II
the Nazis have taken over Europe and are
now moving towards the oil lands of Asia
through the Soviet Union however they
have one obstacle on their way the city
of Stalingrad protected by the soldiers
of the Russian Red Army as the battle in
the city gets more intense a backup
force is sent on its way to help the Red
Army among the soldiers boarding the
train is vasili who has grown to be a
skilled sniper he closely notices the
civilians being chased away to make room
for more soldiers after a short ride
they reached the city and are pulled
into boarding boats to reach the front
line by the looks of the battlefield it
is obvious that the Nazis have
overpowered them entirely and the backup
soldiers are being sent on a suicidal
Mission when the Army realizes this some
soldiers try to flee only to be shot
dead by their own mates for deserting
the Germans take this as an opportunity
and open fire injuring half of their
enemy before they even get a chance to
fight back when the boat finally reaches
the dock the surviving soldiers are
immediately grouped into pairs of two
where only one of them gets a rifle
vasili only gets a few bullets and is
asked to jump in to help his mates after
separating from his pair almost
immediately his only way to survive is
to stay close to the ground and go
undetected seeing that their chances of
winning are slim a few of his fellow
soldiers try escaping only to be killed
by their own people yet again in no time
the Battleground is covered with the
dead bodies of the Russian soldiers a
few moments later a car insurance the
Grim scene but instantly gets hit by a
tank commissioner Daniel off of the
Russian army jumps from the wrecked car
and hides among the dead bodies
pretending to be dead himself he holds
his breath as the Germans come over and
starts shooting the soldiers ensuring
none are alive danilov somehow survives
the assault and waits until they are out
of sight to take a rifle from a Dead
Soldier nearby upon realizing the rifle
is missing ammo he is approached by
vasili who had also been pretending to
be dead he hands over his share of ammo
to the commissioner and tells him to
shoot when an explosion occurs to ensure
they aren't discovered however Danny
love is hesitant because of his lack of
skills so he hands the rifle over to the
Sealy just as another car arrives and
the explosion starts vasili surprises
the commissioner with his excellent
Marksmanship and takes down all of the
enemy snipers he is so impressed that
later when they reach the headquarters
after being rescued he prints out some
pamphlets to spread vasily's
accomplishment the higher officials of
the Red Army realize their defenses are
weak because their soldiers are
unwilling to sacrifice their lives for
the country this is causing the Soviet
forces to weaken so chairman Nikita
Khrushchev steps in to rebuild the
defense system he demands his
subordinates ideas to reevaluate their
strategies but all he gets are the same
old strategies until danilov suggests
that they should deliver hope and
present a hero who shall Inspire
everyone to protect their motherland
taken aback by this Khrushchev asks if
the commissioner will be able to do so
Danny love recommends a vasili and gets
permission to print his heroic tales in
the military newspaper right after the
silly skills are recognized and He is
transferred to the sniper division soon
the tale of his heroic deed reaches
people all over the country making him
the face of the Russian army as well as
a propaganda icon consequently the
Russian sniper has taken quite a toll on
the Germans as they go as far as to
deploy major Irvin Koenig a renowned
Marksman and head of an army sniper
School in Germany in order to kill
vasili one day while vasili is on a
mission he meets a young boy named Sacha
who like every other citizen admires him
Sacha invites him to his home where
danilov brings him letters from his fans
which he has to reply to a while later a
woman named Tanya enters the house she
is a soldier from the local militia who
is like family to the philippovs Vasily
remembers that he had seen her on the
train on his way to Stalingrad and hopes
she remembers him too however he is
disappointed when she only recognizes
him as the war hero his Crush thinks
he's a badass poor guy as the group
chats it is obvious that both Denny and
vasili take an interest in her Danny
love even offers her a job in the
headquarters to decipher German codes
after finding out that she is fluent in
German although hesitant Tanya takes the
job when she realizes that she can save
a lot of soldiers by doing so the next
day vasilia is deployed to a former
department store where an enemy sniper
is causing trouble for the Soviet Army
when he reaches there he spots a shadow
near the window and shoots it dead
confident in his skills he then takes
Ludmila a comrade to go inside and check
only to find out that it was a decoy to
lure them in in addition vasili finds a
blunt of a cigarette and deduces that
the sniper is still inside suddenly
several planes fly past the area bombing
the buildings and making Ludmila Panic
vasili tries to calm her down but she
hastily makes a run for it as a result
the enemy sniper kunig easily spots her
and shoots her to death in the following
scene we see him return to his Hideout
where he gets his shoes cleaned by Sacha
the kid gives him information about
vasili in return for food after the Red
Army learns of koenig's purpose they
hire kulikov koenig's former student to
help vasili vasili kulikov and volodia a
member of the sniper team go into an
abandoned building that has a body set
up to look like it is the enemy sniper
assuming it's a trap they believe they
are on the right track and move to a
different area the enemy Fires at them
but they luckily managed to reach the
safe area without getting hit and after
marking two guys they get ready for
dinner veloja runs to get the soup that
he left in the other room but gets
captured by the enemy in the process
when he refuses to reveal vasily's
whereabouts he is dressed in a German
uniform and sent disguised as their
repairman without any hesitation kulikov
shoots him purposely revealing their
location he then raises a helmet as a
Decoy for Koenig to shoot and reveal his
location as well however Koenig gets a
hint of what they are up to and doesn't
fall for the Trap making them relocate
in a hurry just as they are moving to a
different place Koenig kills kulikov
undermining the
Spirit regardless of the several deaths
it has caused Khrushchev keeps
pressuring Daniel off to continue the
sniper face off in addition Tanya asks
him to transfer her back to the militia
when vasili returns dispirited danilov
promises him that they will get more
Intel on Konig and asks him to make
Tanya stay in the headquarters as
requested Vasily tries to convince her
and learns that her parents were among
the prisoners executed by the Germans so
she wants to join the militia and fight
he understands her choices and gives her
kulikov's rifle supporting her decision
at The Hideout Koenig gets his shoe
cleaned by satcho once again that little
boy loves shoes while inquiring about
vasily's whereabouts the following day
he waits for a vasilia at the location
Sacha provided eagerly anticipating his
arrival after a while vasili and his
comrades stealthily make their way
through the pipes alerting Koenig to
their presence as soon as they emerge
from the pipe Koenig swiftly takes his
shot causing vasili to drop his rifle
and hide behind a rock he forces his
comrade to return to the headquarters
because his hand is injured his return
alerts Tanya and danilov of the
situation and without thinking twice
Tanya goes to rescue vasili at the end
of the pipe vasili constantly makes
efforts to pull his weapon with the help
of the knife and a rope but Koenig gives
him no chance just then a bombing shakes
the whole building and pieces of glass
shatter everywhere which gives Koenig a
clear view of vasili subsequently Tanya
enters through the pipe but vasili yells
at her to stay back he shows her
koenig's location on the same glass
through which he is being watched and
instructs her to reflect light with
another piece of glass Tanya effectively
does her task blinding the enemy for a
second Vasily takes the chance to pick
up his weapon and manages to shoot
koenig's hand before both parties
Retreat later in the evening vasilia and
Tanya celebrate the small victory with
other comrades the following day vasili
tells danalov that he wants to be a
regular Soldier because both Koenig and
the title of a war hero have weighed him
down Daniel off doesn't accept it and
manipulates him using Sacha revealing
that he has been working as a double
agent through the kid they now know the
exact location Koenig is in and Visalia
is tasked to a final mission in the
following scene we see him camouflage
with the dead bodies on the ground
remaining idle just like his grandfather
taught him the scene of the day he
learned to hunt plays before his eyes as
he waits for Koenig eventually he dozes
off and his sniper log is stolen by a
looting German officer the German
command takes the log as evidence of
vasily's death and plans to send Koenig
home as the Soviet propaganda will
benefit if he gets murdered amidst all
of this Koenig is a hundred percent sure
that vasili is still alive then the
headquarters announces vasily's death
through loudspeakers sending the troop
into chaos meanwhile in an attempt to
catch vasili Koenig tells Sacha his next
location believing that the kid will
surely bring the information to the
enemy somewhere else with no hint of
vasily's return Danny love starts
writing an announcement of his death
while the protagonist surprises Everyone
by appearing out of nowhere he seemed
and finds out through Sacha that Tanya
went to the station to attempt to kill
Koenig on her own vasilian danilov go to
rescue her in a hurry and luckily find
her safe happy to see vasilia alive
Tanya plants a kiss on his lips which in
turn makes denilov a jealous little boy
forgetting his responsibility towards
his troop he returns to headquarters and
writes that vasili has become a traitor
meanwhile Koenig whose suspicions have
now been cleared kills Sacha and hangs
him for Vasily and Tanya to see an
angered Tanya wants to avenge his death
but Vasily vows to kill Koenig for her
and sends her to evacuate such as mother
Danny love and Tanya don't know how to
break it to miss phillipoff so they lie
to her that Sacha has joined the Germans
she hopes that her son is still safe and
decides to escape with the special pass
given by Daniel off while trying to get
on the boat a bomb explodes and hurts
Tanya making her fall unconscious the
doctor has no hopes of her surviving so
he doesn't let her into the boat Mrs
philippov however convinces the
Personnel that Tanya is her daughter and
shows them the past before they allow
her to board somewhere else an oblivious
danilov finds vasili and shares the
tragic news of Tanya's death burdening
himself with guilt overwhelmed with
regret he blames himself and decides to
give up on life by exposing himself to
Koenig to sniper wastes no time in
shooting him thus giving away his own
position in a surprising turn of events
Koenig approaches cautiously expecting
Victory but is met with surprise when he
sees vasili waiting for him accepting
his fate Koenig lets vasili shoot him
and dies in The Encounter after the
chaos ends vasili retrieves his rifle
and places it beside danilov's lifeless
body as a sign of respect two months
later when Stalingrad has been freed
from the Germans vasili receives a
letter from Tanya that she is recovering
at the field Hospital eager to see her
again he visits the address mentioned in
the letter and the movie ends as we
witness a heartfelt reunion between the
two subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching